we shot she's gonna have me we shot
she's gonna have it in 1985 we were
doing kick started for the worst
Kickstarter we just had the technology I
was making phone calls making personal
visits write letters so did everything
except so she me it was so sweet was not
around it do you think that people that
are already established are taking away
quote chances from the little guys no
look I understand why people might think
that but that's not the case at all I'm
bringing people to Kickstarter never
heard a Kickstarter I'm talking a lot of
people of color never it Kickstarter
he's never made a pledge on Kickstarter
so I really think that it's a fallacy
it's a misconception and I just played
out it's just plain out wrong with the
capital W that because someone puts five
dollars on my film some who backs my
total five dollars that was five dollars
that a young filmmaker was going to get
and that logic does not just not follow
through I mean there there's concrete
evidence with what mr. Thomas did with
Veronica Mars and what was Zack did with
his film people majority of people who
backed those things had never been on
Kickstarter before but
I think those people back films after
that once they once they made were made
the introduction to Kickstarter so to be
honest I know the course I know that I
mean look I know you had to ask this
question so it's cool the two
co-founders of Kickstarter told me that
you know Ron mr. Thomas had flac he
caught flak Zach caught flak Zach black
and that I would get the same so this is
not a surprise at all but
is this is a I've been hearing stuff for
the very first film she's going to have
it was a portrayal of black women
school days I was airing dirty laundry
do the right thing would make black
people run a muck and right all across
the country when it came out I was
anti-semitic because my characters Joe
Moe and Josh Flatbush and mo better
blues so I just rolled with the punches
and keep going and the fact that I'm
here in my third decade making films is
concrete evidence of that and I'm going
to keep Kurosawa's 85-86 went so you
know I'm not go that long but I had many
many more films many many many more
stories to tell and this little use a
word on you this little brouhaha about
spike lee is comes in bogard kickstarter
and he's taking advantage of the young
up-and-coming filmmakers is is as might
as my good friend mike tyson let's say
is ludicrous for example why would I be
teaching for the past 15 years and why
you if I had not care about young
filmmakers why would I be the artistic
director up in why you graduate film
school if I not cave up young filmmakers
why have I've given that over over
twenty thousand dollars in the spike lee
production fund the young filmmakers and
why you if I not care about
young filmmakers so people say they want
the truth is the truth
you